in a small community in the pacific
northwest a dynamic company is growing
this company has served the equipment
dealer market for 30 years they did it
by following their principles
by being the best and by being honest to
their customers
dis
technology driven
people focused
we do
a great deal of training we talked about
this earlier with our technicians in
particular product updates things are
always changing we spend a great deal of
time and money on training to make sure
they have the latest knowledge on what's
going on with the machinery any updates
what have you
we're fortunate that we are close to
racine where there is a great deal of
case training available as well as iowa
but our sales people as well they need
to learn about the new products every
year so they're going and in our parts
and in other areas we look for
opportunities if someone has an interest
in something that they might like to
attend we're certainly willing to
support that as well but
we see it mostly in our technician area
we try to keep a good handle on the
classes they have had and classes that
they might be interested in taking
we want to make sure that a technician
has
the service level one before they move
to a service level two and that's just
the simple bookkeeping part of it but it
also tells us areas
make sure we have certified technicians
in all areas you want don't want to sell
a piece of equipment if you don't have
the people there to service it and
support it so
case is good about tracking it for us
but we like to do that as well to make
sure we're covering all the bases of the
products that we sell
in a small community in the pacific
northwest a dynamic company is growing
this company has served the equipment
dealer market for 30 years they did it
by following their principles
by being the best and by being honest to
their customers
dis
technology driven
people focused